[Musique]
c'est la première journée de camp le
groupe kemboi rencontre les jeunes
isabelle bahnof c'est une bénévole qui
enseigne le clavier et la barre
sylvain espaces incroyables pour les
jeunes filles quand moi j'avais la rage
j'avais pas une opportunité comme ça
j'avais pas l'espace comme ça n'existait
pas puis à mon école j'étais un peu la
fille bizarre un peu artiste et quand tu
as dit alors je me sentais vraiment pas
à l'aise tout le temps ici je peux
vraiment faire ce que j'aime qui j'ai
pas chrétien genre on dise que chez
excessive ou que ces polyphonies qui
fait les gens jugent pas ici c'est
vraiment le fun comme on sentait pas le
cas au rock de montréal s'inscrit dans
une alliance internationale qui défend
des valeurs féministes et lutte contre
l'homophobie
ils sont une centaine de camps sur tous
les continents de la finlande à
l'abstrait dit en passant par l'afrique
du sud le japon et les etats-unis ou et
demi le concept c'est un organisme qui
promeut la parade des faits et des
jeunes de gens non conformes à travers
la musique
apprendre un instrument de former un
groupe de jouer sur scène complété par
des ateliers sur une variété de sujets
comme la justice sociale les identités
de genre orientation sexuelle moi par
exemple je vais y penser mais ça me
permit tellement d'apprendre ya plein de
choses que j'avais même peu comme qui
pouvaient exister puisqu'elle est ça me
fait vraiment réfléchir se tait comment
les gens pensent
on veut faire la différence pour ces
jeunes j'avais 12 ans et j'étais dans ce
camp là je pense que ça m'aurait permis
de gagner beaucoup d'années de confiance
en moi je pense que ça m'aurait permis
d'être plus ouverte avec moi même je
suis à parce que j'aime la musique
il ya certains ateliers qui sont divisés
selon l'âge puis c'est sûr que quand on
a les 2 à 12 ans on va peut-être moins
dans le détail dans le la théorie
profonde
je sais que chico être évité mais je
trouve que c'est bien aussi qu'est ce ça
parce que ça me permet d'en savoir un
peu plus mais je suis vraiment ici plus
pour la musique telle celle de faire des
bébés
quand tu commences à faire la batterie
les beats que j'ai appris ce sont des
beats vraiment cents que les bétons
utilisent et c'est comme ça que j'ai
appris
[Musique]
lui c'est pas d'être parfait mais c'est
d'apprendre de prendre le state dans le
fond de faire de la musique faire du
bruit parce que pour nous une attitude
rock c'est pas de jouer parfaitement
c'est pas d'être c'est d'être une rock
star d'enfants et je vais me faire des
amis créer de la musique parce que
j'adore femmes arrêtées chichi parce que
on rencontre plein de gens cool c'est
plus facile de parler de deux choses qui
ne sont pas habituellement par les dents
genre à l'école ou avec des parents ici
seuls veille miley radio canada montréal
[Musique]